SAFE.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN STEVE
SCALISE THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE ON
THE BATTLE OVER THE BORDER
THE SO-CALLED BIG GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN WHICH IS NEVER
REALLY A SHUTDOWN SOUTH
CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM IS WITH US.
SENATOR, IT MAKES MY BLOOD
BOIL BECAUSE HAS HAPPENED
TIME AND AGAIN.
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T
RESPECT OUR LAWS OR OUR
SOVEREIGNTY COME TO AMERICA,
COMMIT MORE CRIMES.
THEY ARE IN CUSTODY.
AND THEN THEY ARE LITERALLY
LIKE A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA
THEY ARE PROTECTED FROM THE
LAWS OF LAND.
THEY COMMIT HORRIFIC CRIMES.
NOW, IS CALIFORNIA, ARE THEY
GOING TO PAY THE FUNERAL
COSTS?
ARE THEY GOING TO PAY THE
COLLEGE TUITION?
HOW DO THEY EXPLAIN TO THIS
5-MONTH-OLD LITTLE BOY THAT
DADDY IS NEVER COMING BACK
AGAIN?
WELL, THESE POLICIES THAT
MAKE IT MORE LIKELY THAT
TERRORISTS, DRUG DEALERS AND
CRIMINALS CAN COME TO
AMERICA AND HAVE SAFE HAVEN.
SO YOU SAID BEFORE, I THINK
STEVE IS A GREAT GUY.
HE SAID DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
FOR BORDER SECURITY.
YEAH, THEY ARE.
EXCEPT WHEN TRUMP IS
PRESIDENT.
I HAVE SEEN THEM IN ACTION.
THEY HAVE ALL VOTED FOR 25,
$42 BILLION.
YOU NAME THE NUMBER FOR
BORDER SECURITY.
THEY WON'T GIVE A DIME TO
THIS PRESIDENT BECAUSE THEY
WANT HIM TO FAIL.
WALLS WORK.
TRUMP SAID MAKE A DEAL.
NANCY PELOSI.
>> Sean: YOU OFFERED
COMPROMISE.
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY CARE
ABOUT THE DACA KIDS WHAT IS
YOUR COMPROMISE?
>> COMPROMISE IS GIVE
PRESIDENT THE $5 BILLION WE
NEED FOR WALL/BORDER
SECURITY AS A DOWN PAYMENT
TO SECURING THE BORDER.
THE DACA POPULATION ABOUT
700,000, GIVE THEM WORK
PERMITS, THREE YEAR WORK
PERMITS SO THEY DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT GETTING
DEPORTED ANY TIME SOON.
THE TPS PEOPLE CAME HERE
FROM WAR TORN AREAS
HURRICANES AND FLOODS, WE
KNOW THEIR LEGAL STATUS NO
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP AND
CALL IT A DAY.
IT'S CALLED COMPROMISE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID LET'S
MAKE A DEAL.
THE DEMOCRATIC SUPPORTS IS
BASICALLY GO TO HELL.
THEY ARE GOING TO SPEND A
BILL MITCH MCDONNELL IS NERN
EVERY WE NEED THE WALL.
THEY ALL VOTED FOR THE WALL.
THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING TO
GET THE WALL IS TO FIGHT FOR
IT.
>> Sean: THIS IS A BATTLE TO
ME WORTH HAVING.
I KNOW IT'S CONVENIENT.
I SUPPORT ALL THOSE
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES.
I DON'T WANT THEM CAUGHT IN
THE POLITICAL CROSSFIRE.
THEY DESERVE THEIR BACK PAY.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: IT'S THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN THAT THEY
ARE NOT VIEWED AT ESSENTIAL
SERVICES.
>>
BUT DOES THE
PRESIDENT HAVE OTHER OPTIONS
FOR THE WALL?
FOR EXAMPLE, WHY IS THIS THE
NOT VIEWED.
HE IS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, IS HE IN
CHARGE OF NATIONAL SECURITY
OF THIS COUNTRY.
WHY COULDN'T DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT FUNDS BE USED TO
SECURE OUR BORDER TO STOP
THE DRUG TRAFFICKING.
HUMAN TASKING AND EVENING
THE CRIMINAL GANGS AND 3700
TERRORISTS THAT STEVE
SCALISE MENTIONED THAT WERE
CAUGHT TRYING TO CROSS OUR
BORDER.
WHY IS THAT NOT A NATIONAL
SECURITY DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
ISSUE?
>> CAN YOU MOVE SOME MONEY
AROUND BUT HE WILL GET FOOD
THERE WILL BE LAWSUITS IN
CALIFORNIA TO STOP ANY
EFFORT TO HAVE OTHER
AGENCIES FUND THE BORDER.
BUT THERE IS SOME MONEY YOU
CAN USE FOR SURE.
WHY SHOULD THIS PRESIDENT
HAVE TO PLAY THAT GAME?
WHY SHOULD DONALD TRUMP HAVE
TO DO THAT WHEN DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS AND REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS IN THE PAST WERE
ABLE TO GET MONEY TO SECURE
THE BORDER ON DEMOCRATS?
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
>> HE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO
THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS MOVIE
IS GOING TO END BUT WE ARE
NOT GIVING UP UNTIL WE GET
THE MONEY.
>> Sean: IF IT TAKES 150
DAYS, I THINK THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY NEEDS TO STAND UNITED
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN YOU.
I DON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
SOME OF YOUR COLLEAGUES, BUT
SAVING LIVES AND STOPPING
HUMAN DRUG TRAFFICKING IS
WORTH THE FIGHT.
HE NEEDS TO HOLD THE LINE.
>> LET ME TELL YOU HOW OUR
GOVERNMENT WORKS.
ANY BILL PASSED FROM THE HOW
FAST HAS TO COME TO THE
SENATE AND HAS TO GET 60
VOTES FOR IT TO BE SIGNED
INTO LAW THE PRESIDENT HAS
TO SIGN IT.
HE IS NOT GOING TO SIGN A
BILL THAT DOESN'T HAVE MONEY
FOR THE WALL.
I WILL TELL YOU EXACTLY HOW
FAR THIS IS GOING TO END.
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
CHALLENGETH PRESIDENT TO
COMPROMISE.
IF THEY CONTINUE TO SAY NO,
THEY WILL PAY A PRICE WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
MOST AMERICANS WANT TO DO
TWO THINGS.
THEY WANT TO SECURE OUR
BORDER.
>> IF HE GIVES IN NOW,
THAT'S THE END OF 2019 IN
TERMS OF HIM BEING AN
EFFECTIVE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE END OF
HIS PRESIDENT.
DONALD TRUMP HAS MADE A
PROMISE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IS HE GOING TO SECURE OUR
BORDER.
EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE PAST
BORDER FUNDING.
NOW THEY ARE CHANGING THEIR
FIND.
>> Sean: IT'S TOO IMPORTANT.
TOO MANY LIVES AT STAKE.
TO MUCH DANGER TO THE
COUNTRY.
SENATOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> THAT'S ET END OF US IF WE
GIVE UP ON THIS INNER AS
REPUBLICANS.